حكم النهائي بالاعدام لقاتل فرح اكبر في
قضيه هزه الكويتيه اعتقال ابو كيان صاحب
اعلان بيع المخدرات في مصر لاعبان انجلترا
اسطحبان معهما قط ضالا الى لندن هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تابعوها على العربيه
واسمعوها كذلك على العربيات
نبدا من الكويت حيث اسفلت محكمه التمييز
الستار على واحده من اشهر جرائم القتل
وابشعها في البلاد بعد ما قضت باعدام
المتهم بقتل المواطنه فرح اكبر صحيفه
القباسل المحليه اوضحت ان محكمه التمييز
الغات حكم محكمه الاستئناف القاضي بالحبس
المؤبد فيما كانت جريمه قتل فرح تحولت الى
قضيه رائعه
وهو عسكري يعمل في وزاره الدفاع على
ملاحقه الضحيه حيث قطع الطريق امامها
وحاول خطفها ثم قام بتسديد طعنات بالسكين
في صدرها ما ادى الى وفاتها
بعدما اثارت قصته موجه واسعه من السخريه
في السوشل ميديا اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
المصريه عن القاء القبض على شخص يدعى ابو
كيان للمكيفات تقارير اوضحت ان قصه ابو
كيان بدات عندما نشر اعلانا عبر مواقع
التواصل مصحوبا بعنوان ورقم التواصل لبيع
خمس انواع بالجمله والترسئه ليثير ضجه
واسعه في مصر لكن الطريق في الامر ان اول
اتصال تلقى ابو كيان هو من عناصر الشرطه
لتلحقه وتقبض عليه ليس هذا فقط بل عثرت
على كميه كبيره من المواد المخدره بحوزته
الى بريطانيا هذه المره حيث تضررت اجزاء
واسعه من البلاد بسبب الجليد والضباب
والثلوج اما اثار حاله من الفوضى بين
المسافرين على الطرق وفي القطارات
والمطارات ايضا مقاطع متداوله اظهرت عشرات
المسافرين وهم يفترشون ارضيه احدى مطارات
العاصمه لندن نتيجه الغاء رحلاتهم بسبب
اغلاق المدرج نتيجه الهطول الكثيف للثلوج
فيما ذكرت هيئه بي بي سي ان اكثر من 50
رحله الغياده في مطار هيثرو الذي يعد اكبر
مطارات العاصمه البريطانيه بسبب الضباب
والجديد
نبقى في بريطانيا حيث وجه عدد من المفكرين
السياسيين والمؤرخين الملكين تحذيرا الى
الامير هاري وزوجته ماجن ماركل مفاده لا
تحضر مراسم تتويج الملكه تشارلز الثالث
العضو المخضرم في حزب المحافظين ديفيدنار
قال لصحيفه ديدي ميل انه لا ينبغي على
هاري المجيء الى مراسم التتويج مشيرا الى
انهما يجنيان الاموال من المتاجره بسمعه
عائلتهما بين الناس فيما قالت المؤرخ
الملكيه انطونيو فريزر انها تعمل في ان
يلزم الزوجان منزلهما حتى لا يكذب
الانتباه بعيدا عن الملك تشارلز والسيده
جميله
وفي خبرنا الاخير وبعد خروج انجلترا من
المنافسات في بطوله كاس العالم بعد
الهزيمه امام فرنسا اصر ثنائي مانشستر
سيتي كيل وكر و جون ستونز عدم مغادره قطر
خاليه الوقائي شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
اشارت الى ان المدافعين الصحابه معهما الى
الديار قطا ضالا تعرفها عليه بمقر
التدريبات المنتخب الانجليزي لافته الى ان
القط الذي اطلق عليه ستونز اسم ديف سيقضي
اربعه اشهر في حجر الصحي قبل ان ينضم
مجددا الى ثنائي